[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show we
have news about chelsea manning chelsea
manning the former army intelligence
analyst who was convicted at the time as
bradley manning of disclosing classified
information to WikiLeaks was ultimately
a released early from prison as a result
of President Obama's action near the end
of his presidency she is now running for
the US Senate seat in Maryland and she
has put out a campaign video and I'm
terrible at predicting election results
but I think Chelsea Manning has
absolutely no chance of becoming the
next senator from Maryland now do you
have anything on this already
I mean she's not the incumbent so you
can't make her the favor that's for
certain yeah she's probably a long shot
but the difference between her and some
other obscure candidates would be that
she has name recognition yes she does
she definitely has more name recognition
than I mean at one point it was pretty
significant name recognition given how
much was in the news about her trial and
her disclosing documents to Wikileaks so
on and so forth the only problem any -
yes indeed the only problem though is
that it's a tension that was for doing
things that a lot of the country thinks
were really terrible things so I don't
know I mean I know good put any
publicity is good publicity sort of but
it's also not under that logic Roy Moore
would have one right because the
publicity around the horrible things
that he did would have gotten him more
votes and if people disagree with what
you did and to be clear I'm not drawing
any analogy between what Roy Moore is
accused of doing and what Chelsea
Manning did the idea that any publicity
is good publicity I don't know that it
applies to elections necessarily well
what she did was certainly polarizing
among the American public and I'm sure
if you interviewed half of people you
would find that they think that she's a
hero yes the other half think that she's
a traitor but you're not dealing with
the entire American public you're
dealing with just voters in Maryland and
in this first round you're just dealing
with Democratic primary but yes indeed
and I think out of Democrats maybe even
in Meryl
the majority of them would think that
she is a hero for doing what sure what
percentage would prefer her over the
alternatives is the question right right
but I think it is a very interesting
candidacy her platform is kind of
related to I mean I think generally we
can say that it's about questioning
institutions of power and the control
and influence that they have over our
lives which does sort of connect with
her mission and having released those
documents to Wikileaks documents that
were of course illegally taken based on
the access she had to military
intelligence databases so there's some
connection to the crime / activism that
she participated in so that might rival
to some people I mean just take a look
at her campaign ad it has a lot to do
with you know maybe like campaign
finance reform or releasing some of the
racial tensions that's going on in the
country sure but one thing that won't
help her I think is her tweet from just
about a week ago that said F the police
unlike a Police Appreciation Day
particularly in Maryland right I mean
where there has been a particularly
escalated situation between police and
protesters in Baltimore over the last
few years yeah I find this very
interesting I just don't think it's
going to go too far but listen I thought
Trump wasn't going to win so Who am I to
predict elections yeah if she was
running against like some true
progressive champion like Lizabeth war
and her Bernie Sanders I would say that
she has no shot but he is running
against Ben Cardin who pretty much no
one knows about I mean he's just this
older corporate Democrat who isn't kind
of rally the base but not unpopular in
Maryland I think he's generally
well-liked in Maryland yeah I think that
goes to the thing about a you can
support their own the power of insanity
yeah no I get that so long shot it's a
long shot but it's interesting and I'll
tell you if anything else comes up with
it Donald Trump last week sort of
surprised lawmakers when they met at the
White House when he said that it might
be something to look at to go back to a
form of earmarks where he said maybe
that brings people together in our
system right now the way to set up will
never bring people together earmarks are
these provisions that are that used to
be allowed in bills where funds would go
to specific recipients so as you can
imagine it opens the door so
significantly to quid pro quos because
you can get you can receive a campaign
donor
and then you can actually earmark money
in a bill not just for an industry not
just in support of a particular project
but what was that did you hear that that
was a very odd noise noise was that a
kitchen that's that was that from
upstairs that was a very bizarre noise
not like a spoon hitting a pitch sounded
like a spoon hitting a plate that was so
strange I don't know where that came
from but let's hope someone's not about
to fall through here from the kitchen
upstairs we'd have an old amra holding
their lunch yeah the problem with
earmarks is that it so easily lends
itself to corruption now I know that you
might be hearing me say this and you get
you would say hold on a second David you
don't need earmarks to do the quid pro
quos because you can get a donation from
a I don't know an oil company in a
particular state and then you can have
that lawmaker pass a bill that says the
money will go to this industry in this
state for companies that are doing some
very particular activity and there might
only be one or two companies doing that
so even without naming the companies or
the individuals you kind of still can
earmark money that will go to specific
places but still being able to earmark
money so specifically for me is just the
height of the quid pro quo corruption
door opening and I think it's an
absolute and total disaster yeah it's
interesting how Trump proposed this idea
during the daca and immigration or four
meetings that they had by saying well
you guys used to get along so much
better I would see Republicans and
Democrats having lunch together and
maybe one way to fix that to get back to
that would be to bring back ear max it's
correlation right laughed at him it's
correlation versus causation because
there are endless reasons why Democrats
and Republicans maybe at some previous
point got along better Trump could be
part of that reason
Trump's presence it's so outrageous that
it has furthered the divide between
Republicans who seem to be supporting
their party leader to the extent that
Trump is that regardless of what he does
and Democrats who realize the insanity
of it but yeah the bigger point I'm
trying to make is just because you at
one point had earmark
and it was perceived that Republicans
and Democrats got along better there is
no evidence whatsoever that it was
because of the earmarks that they were
getting along better doesn't make any
sense I mean I think proponents would
say well if you want a park in Maryland
then you have to support the bridge in
Utah otherwise there would be no
incentive I mean I guess the the better
way to do it would you just have a
groundswell of support for an
infrastructure bill sure across the
entire country rather than attaching
something like a bridge to I don't know
some disclosed secret national defense
spending authorization the problem is
that's one problem right which is we
need clean bills we need medals where we
are just it's it's we're not pulling in
all sorts of other stuff pet projects
and whatnot or but the pork yes indeed
the other problem is that even
infrastructure spending the way Trump
wanted to do it or wants to do it it's a
total crony handout and it's designed
with all sorts of mechanisms really
specific mechanisms involving loans and
repayment and contracts and all sorts of
other stuff that it is designed to
actually be it sounds like an
infrastructure spending program but it's
really crony capitalist handouts to
Trump's buddies in the construction
industry so you you can't even say we
can agree with Trump on infrastructure
spending yeah we can agree with him at
the very high level on infrastructure
spending but as soon as we get to how
exactly what he do it it's absolutely
disgusting and I think that this earmark
remark isn't why you would expect from
the drain the swamp president knows well
and do you want people in Congress to
get together and control like they used
control like they used to
well you should probably do is have more
strict campaign finance reform indeed
because then these representatives don't
have to adhere to their donors as much
and can actually listen to the people of
course and when there is commonality on
some sort of bills and proposition they
can actually support it and get
something done
instead of it depending on all this
other nonsense that gets pulled into it
no question about it
okay let's talk a little bit about this
story relating to Aziz Ansari the
comedian I don't know how I feel about
the entire controversy around the story
but to give you the background as you
probably know there's been this huge
groundswell of accusations basically I
think it's fair to say exclusively
against men for inappropriate sexual
conduct assault harassment of mostly
women although
with the Kevin Spacey circumstances it
actually was involving all men as far as
I recall
so Aziz Ansari was accused in an article
by a woman who says that she met him and
they were in touch
they met in person and danced one day
and then they stayed in touch via phone
and eventually they had a date and they
went dinner and Aziz Ansari a very
abruptly called for the check at the end
of dinner and they went back to his
place and they were having wine and he
started kissing her and he started
touching her and she wanted to sort of
slow things down I think she said let's
take it easy and then it led to oral sex
being performed and then ultimately Aziz
Ansari called her an uber and she left
and the next day she contacted him I
believe it was via text and said your
behavior yesterday was inappropriate and
he responded I'm paraphrasing along the
lines of it appears as though I misread
the signals that you sent the situation
and I apologized for my actions and this
has blown up into two camps that are
pretty much polarized one saying that
Aziz Ansari did something that is I
don't know this is the right term but as
bad as what many of the others have done
in terms of up to an including rape and
sexual assault and there has been an
emboldened counter movement which is
saying this is why the me2 movement is a
problem because you have real instances
of sexual assault and then you have this
one where a woman basically said let's
slow it down but at no point did she
really indicate that she wanted to leave
or she didn't want to be doing whatever
she was doing with Aziz Ansari and it's
mudding up the waters and bla bla bla
bla bla I the where I have a real
problem commenting on this is as a
heterosexual man in Western society in
the United States
I've never even come close to being in a
situation where I was even remotely
concerned that I might be in a coercive
situation the way that many women in the
United States have
claim to do so I could read the story
and I could give my set my thoughts and
I could say I think Aziz Ansari did do
something wrong or I could say you know
what I don't think he did anything wrong
because she didn't really indicate that
she didn't want to be there and then it
would be completely legitimate for a
woman to come to me and say David you
don't understand just because she wasn't
physically forced to do anything the
atmosphere in the room could have been
one where she felt as though he might
have become very angry and there would
have been repercussions if she's just
tried to leave I don't know what that's
like I've never experienced that so I
feel like my ability to really comment
on the merits of this woman's story it
is limited right what I can say
comfortably is I do believe there is a
spectrum of incidents in terms of
seriousness and aggression I don't think
this is anywhere near the top of the
list in terms of what we've heard of
does that mean that Aziz Ansari did
nothing wrong now I really can't say
that I I feel like I really can't and
this isn't you know I've talked about
this problem of for example the black
lives matter events that don't allow or
don't want to hear from white voices and
I think that's fair terribly
counterproductive right we should all be
working together if there's white people
who want to participate in the black
lives matter movement they should be
encouraged to do so because we really
need consensus around that this is not
because I feel like as someone who is
not a woman I'm not allowed to or it's
not okay for me to express my opinion I
just generally have difficulty fully
understanding what she might have felt
like because I've never even come close
to being in something remotely similar
to this what can I say what can I get
and that was very well said I mean the
thing I would add is that you're dealing
with nonverbal cues it seems like I
don't think she ever came out and said
that she doesn't want to have sex so
specifically he said let's take it let's
chill out for a second or something
along those right and they were also
exchanging oral sex shortly so who
really knows I guess and I think think
that is part of the problem especially
because when you're talking about sex I
mean you have to deal with obviously
consent but you never really know if you
can read the other person absolutely
entirely so I you know you can't rank
this certainly with any of the other
sexual misconduct allegation
I think it's in a league of its own I
don't think you know you should face any
employment repercussions with this but
you know I I don't think it is troubling
to some degree yeah I I just I wish I
could have a more defined view but every
time I start going in one direction or
the other I realize that I don't really
know what I'm talking about because I've
never come close to being in her
situation in a situation of these
circumstances I hope and believe I've
never put any woman in something
approximating what she's describing a
situation like what she's describing I J
I genuinely don't know that I really
have a perspective where I can say much
or add anything I mean it seems to me
like it was a date that went wrong and
when she made it clear that she wanted
to go home she went home I mean he
ordered her an uber right I don't know
it horrible he should have called the
lift I mean we know politically he
should have called the lift for sure
yeah I mean I don't know if she should
have went public with this story though
I don't know and then that's her call I
guess I I really am very tentative about
taking a strong opinion because I just
don't think so that's why I'll stop and
encourage people in the audience we get
in touch and let me know what you the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]